[Music]
in celebrity trend news hmm
what happened submitted by a dick tip oh
just the tip just the tip celebrities
are now paying $650 for penis facials
what are you talking about Oh tell me to
convince celebrities to like just let us
rub dicks all over their faces think
about that you know I was seeking the
dick was getting exfoliated like the
skin so I thought they put a clay mask
Oh yours is way better every time we was
thinking someone just laying down and a
bunch of dicks just [ __ ] running all
over they rub their [ __ ] all over your
face they think pre-cum is great for the
[ __ ] skin it's like I swear to God
Tiffani Amber Thiessen it keeps you
looking 30 and she's like us I'm here
burn if I have to wait that's totally
right from yeah so this facial is called
Hollywood EGF which stands for epidermal
growth factor and so what it is it's
they take newborn baby boy's foreskin
and then they get cells and then they
clone those cells in a lab and then
somehow they use that for this facial
leave these boys alone is it foreskin
only so like when I cut the they cut the
tip off they'd send that skin to the lab
and then they clone it and then they
turn that into a chemical that helps
your face yeah exactly
yeah how'd they find that that is weird
consists of chemical peels
micro-needling
to help stem cells and peptides to
penetrate and promote collagen growth an
electrifying mass to calm the skin and
then that growth factor serum which is
baby foreskin kepi just inject baby
foreskin clone baby foreskin thing that
[ __ ] in the no no it's like well that's
a dick face mask or or they're injecting
it micro needling makes up like a
million little tiny cuts in your face
and then so this stuff goes inside and
then your body's like oh we need to fix
this there's like a bunch of cuts so a
bunch of blood and collagen all the
stuff that comes to the forefront of
your face all right I'll just look old
yeah great
I'll just look money no Gaea watch your
rub dried cockle over your face
Tod baby [ __ ] yeah baby big baby dick
skin Jesus became popular when Kate
Blanchet told Sandra Bullock about her
getting this vid Sandra Bullock's face
looks [ __ ] up now cuz she got it done
ding just here at ocean's 11 she had so
much was insane I mean yeah
oceans 8 yeah you look fine no her face
looks like this like she doesn't really
fit oh wait do we do it again you look
hot oh gee oh my god let's do that
that's what faces face left people the
bigger they get that night no I look so
hot no no that's like the 80s plastic
surgery dude that's like now though have
you seen have you seen what's her face
from friends Monica no but she toned it
down she looks better now on me but she
had that thing maybe that's what it
looks like in the beginning and it's
slowly it does my Sandra Bullock looks
like Michael Jackson and oceans II know
we're watching it I'll say wait but I
just saw her in the show for his Netflix
thing is she hot as [ __ ] well I probably
settled back down quite settle down
after I couldn't look at her face cuz
I'm just like dude like you were so
beautiful like what did you do why do
you want to look like a salamander why
mostly just look at her but anyway yeah
Kate Beckinsale so hot
Thanks okay see how many Kate's did this
is it Cate Blanchett another Kate
[ __ ] Kate Bosworth did it - exactly
Kate Upton alright so she wrote on
Instagram after a long flight I do like
to lie down and be covered in a mask of
liquefied clone foreskins frankly who
doesn't she posted this so she's funny
she gets the joke posted this photo with
that potentially deleted it there's
liquid for skin on your face and a
filter let's not forget the filter and
the lighting but she's still fine but
don't you love how it give Kate
Beckinsale doesn't she have to leave but
a Sarah Silverman doesn't it everyone's
like you
she's already set herself up his trash
expectation yeah so the woman who it's
not shocking Georgia Lewis this is what
she looks like and she goes celebrity
facials she's a master troll that's good
kind of like stem cells right putting
stem cells on your face yes I think
technically that's what it is
the baby foreskin probably has a ton of
stem cells in it Oh kind of like the
vampire facial that's what they do they
get your own blood and then they put a
hemoglobin Center they spin it and then
they're gonna take your stem cell and
foreskin well I think like baby like a
lot of baby tissues have regenerative
properties there you go because in the
umbilical cord you could save that and
then replicate the stem cell right and
it's also in your spinal yeah cuz I
heard that the process is pretty brutal
like you got to get a big [ __ ] needle
and go in your [ __ ] spine or like for
what first vital to just get spit stem
cells out yeah yeah we just got yeah
I'll just look oldest [ __ ] I'm cool yeah
the other stuff that's cool is like if
you need to rebuild a shoulder that's
tight I like that yeah yeah when you can
grow organs that's gonna be so sick they
do well yeah but it's not like common I
think sometimes it gets rejected still
but I think if it started with your stem
cells or something in some way it's a
lot of Fighters get the stem cell stuff
now not here right you like Brazil yeah
like Germany like cuz I think we have
our medical laws or a little bit not as
progressive ply because of religion so a
lot of like UFC fighters oh go it's like
Germany or Brazil or other places to get
stem cells done and then they come back
and they're like a new person
well it's also cuz our FDA system is
very slow it's like tastes like [ __ ]
10 years to get something approved and
millions and millions of dollars in [ __ ]
but dude Andrew Luck did the same a
Colts quarterback he did the same I
think he did some some kind of
experimental thing in in England because
he had a bad shoulder and it worked like
[ __ ] gangbusters he's been killing it
I don't know [ __ ] about this sighs [ __ ]
I just want them to heal me if I get
hurt when they can grow like a new ACL
or some [ __ ] it's gonna change
everything do that's gonna be tight cuz
then like right now if a football guy
gets injured it's tons of he's done for
you
a CL but even that's crazy because back
in the day that is a career-ending
injury and now people bounce back in a
year or two years it was a career-ending
day ACLs career-ending maybe just like
ten years ago
Wow Haley's here it's crazy what still
can be if you don't like bounce back
yeah but a lot of guys do do you think
if science gets so crazy to a point
where you can eventually just live
forever would you want to do it yeah
[ __ ] yes
yeah because at any point you could
probably still choose to die so why not
go further dude what if we're on a cold
sack and we get to live forever that's
it I hear the same stories about 2078
that's not sure we'd have news stories
we've been friends for how long already
like 10 15 years 12 years we're not
talking you'd have all news stories over
feet you don't live in like all of that
yeah yeah we lived on the same property
that was pretty fun we let her know yeah
it was hard way we live closer to each
other in the same house we date each
other cuz we all live so differently but
if we live close to each at the stick
you have your own [ __ ] yeah you have
your own I mean humans have been doing
that for thousands of years yeah Jess
don't get sick of each other look people
that live in mud you can sing your own
house yeah you're not coming in at block
party all right
I was doing a bit I'm kidding you can
come you're too good no that'd be so
fine imagine like oh like we could do
that thing that you guys were mentioning
earlier what those friends have that
bottle those houses and then we're all
in the nestled and shared one marble
house that'd be awesome then we can have
our own pool parties on them and be
always clean and healthy fresh linens so
we're gonna start a GoFundMe guys for
the best friend fund yeah if you guys
don't mind we're gonna put the link in
the description below please support us
with any money you can't cuz we want a
big ask your parents for money really
need like 18 million dollars to buy the
courses on the same toilet suck we could
do it now if we learn how to make houses
out of grass we all have blog channels
even we all live on holder sac that
would be nuts
that'd be that would be next-level
YouTube [ __ ] it's like The Truman Show
but like a little cold a sack block we
could just set up cameras everywhere so
we do you have to cam
we just walk around and content happens
we'll call it the cul-de-sac better
content happens that way to the cold of
the cold and I'll go to your guys's
cameras and the spray paint I'm so long
your channel makes money it's really
good if you guys make buddy and we can't
pay our goddamn mortgage then we're
gonna have to leave then we all leave
together I'm gonna manage the HOA and
I'm gonna ban all spray painting cameras
yeah why you're the only house making
money you're just paying for the rest of
us stupid wash it off after one day
we'll be in the HOA and Nicky Berg you
must have 1,000 plants in your yard like
you have to have at least 10 dogs yeah
it'll be a jungle it's like we must have
won barbecue party every Saturday yeah I
always wanted to go to those block
parties where they actually use the road
you ever seen that yeah they actually
closed an entire like Street and the
whole street we were just walking and
trick-or-treating and everyone in that
house like went all out or that
neighborhood went all out on their homes
they have barbecues outside Billy oh
yeah they did in their in their own home
that's what I want to do I can you do it
pretty because like the public came to
as I saw it in movies I don't want the
public to come nah it's gonna be so many
people trying to pitch us business ideas
and [ __ ] ask us to listen to their
[ __ ] record I mean like their album
or like it's like check out my clothing
line here's why it's different yeah
they're like yo check out my youtube
channel like I'm just a rapper trying to
make it please click my channel and
subscribe because I promise it'll be
good content you won't believe what I'm
doing on my channel and I'm just like
man I'll just try to have a barbecue
right now stop you're always fighting
with people
[Music]